I hate intros cahaya food ooh season 2
free kick things off with the new school
EUR and the introduction of Sumida hana
no you just got dumped and is desperate
to find a new guy she's thirsty as [ __ ]
for Tai Chi so she's creeping and trying
to get close to him in season 1 we
learned that the Kadett 2 Club is in
jeopardy of losing their club room so
they're trying to find new members to
retain it they have a bunch of new
applicants so they have to go through
and weed out the ones who aren't that
serious
Sumida is among the applicants because
she's trying to get close to tai chi chi
hiya teaches the first-years the basics
while Tai Chi goes to practice at how
did this society with his sights set on
reaching class eh tsamina ditches
practice to go talk to him and she falls
even more in love with him
episode 2 sue made a secretly follows
Tai Chi to the society where she starts
to learn more about the game
boom ex practice with the first years
that she high as teaching is a lot
smaller thanks to her smashing them in
their first practice by the 3rd practice
there's only one guy lab named Tsukuba
but suma day shows up also which raises
their spirits a bit however upon talking
to her Chihaya and oay learned that she
isn't taking kata to that seriously she
is just there for Tai Chi we learned
that Tsukuba is really good at second
verse kata town where the reader skips
the first verse and his team never loses
competitions some of his skills transfer
over to normal cat at up but for the
most part he's still pretty new well
practising Chi hyah tries convincing
suma day to cut her nails so that nobody
gets hurt suma day tries reiterating the
fact that she isn't taking cut into that
seriously but accidentally lets it slip
that she's just there for Tai Chi she
takes up crying in bears but Tai Chi
doesn't really care because we all know
he's super wet 40 aiya
oh wait convinces her to come back and
she decides to take cut it to slightly
more seriously so she cuts her nails
while also studying and memorizing the
poems
episode 3 we get our first look at her
boy auditor who finishes second in a
class a tournament with over a hundred
people competing losing only to his
senior at their society she meets you mu
tau we also learned that him and all the
other characters have their eyes set on
the national high school competition
that's coming up again this year jump
ahead to the high school Nationals
qualifiers where mrs. owl goes again
shoot akin Academy pour their first
match they plan out who's gonna be
playing and komando offers to sit out
the first game so that sooner they can
play for the second round they're
planning
benching Oh way for scuba so that he can
get in West highs head with his
signature rape smile
this allows him to easily win the first
round and while that's going on ouchy
covers for the club not getting five new
members meaning that they can keep the
club room for now
in the second round against West High
Tsukuba busts out all of his mental
warfare tactics and even though he loses
his match they still take the series
advancing further in the last scene
Shinobu gets the news that it is playing
again and it appears they have some sort
of history episode for for the third
round of the qualifiers they play
against home a high school who are being
coached by Super Gucci you might
remember him from season one as the
Easter representative in the machine
Queen qualifiers third she is struggling
during the match and falls behind while
doubting his abilities thanks to some
advice from holida as well as some moral
support from Chihaya he is able to bring
the match back and they win advancing to
the finals just like last year's high
school qualifiers they are up against
Haku Academy episode five these
qualifiers are different in the sense
that the winner and runner-up get to go
to Nationals but both teams are still
determined to win before Hoku as
matchups hero is known for his Derrick
card readings to perfectly predict their
opponents lineup allowing them to choose
favorable matchups
however he doe goes behind his team's
back and makes the matchups even to
prove that they can win in a straight-up
match pseudo who used to be in Haku
Academy shows up to be the reader for
the finals once the matches get underway
Misha gets demolished and is the first
one out Jiraiya starts to fall behind
because she's teaching herself how to
integrate the accuracy she observed from
Shinobi's playstyle as well as the
ability to hear multi-syllable cards
like soooo does combining their
strengths episode 6 flannels end up
being extremely close with the last four
matches coming down to one card
sudden-death Hoku all split their cards
basically guaranteeing their win but
Taichi and she hiya practice aggressive
swings which gets in their head Hiro
ends up making a fault losing his match
to Taichi and now the match isn't
guaranteed anymore when the last card is
red now you two ng hiya get to the card
at the same time meaning the victory
goes to Haku because it was on their
side in the last scene Tsukuba and his
brothers along with Tsunade joined
chihaya's caught at a society to be top
I ha tada episode 7 this episode is
pretty filler ask with the
how to tickle up allowing the concert
ban to use the floor above them as
storage instead of giving up their room
they return the favor by playing to
school's anthem and wishing them good
luck at nationals
yeah we jump ahead to the start of the
high school nationals being held at ohmy
shrine again yep saluting for their
first match they're placed against a
bunch of foreigners meanwhile Sumer day
and kuma no go to scout the other
threats in the tournament since they
aren't playing super day watches mega mo
Osaka who is the Western rep for the
Queen qualifiers but lost to ume
representing Eastern Japan back to the
match the foreigners plate caught a
temporary differently than what
everybody is used to but they aren't
about to lose to some uncultured foreign
swine so they smash them in advance to
the next round in the last scene audit
arrives at the shrine where he is
greeted by Shinobu episode 9 Shinobu is
back to being hot after she loses the
weight she put on in season 1 we learned
that her not too tight used to play
against each other a lot when they were
kids and audit I would kill her like
everybody else he faced who later runs
into an old acquaintance who's in a bit
of a pinch bear short a player after he
got stuck in traffic so they guilt trip
a data into being there standing whoever
this is against the rules so he has to
take off his glasses and wear face masks
he ends up falling behind since he can't
see and feels bad for the team because
they are losing so he decides to get
serious quilling his way back from a
15-car deficit he goes on to win his
match however his old instructor had
recognized him and since they were
caught breaking the rules there's a
possibility that he won't be allowed to
participate in the individual tournament
episode 10 misses I was 3rd matches
against Yamaguchi me oka a well-known
school whose team is full of
intellectuals trying to get better for
their quiz team they also have an
unorthodox style of constantly moving
their cards around playing to their
strong memory back over the auditor who
was waiting around to hear what the
officials decide his punishment should
be
we excused the entrance of Shinobu who
hears that he might not be able to play
she wants to play against him so she
steps in saying that if he can't play
then she refuses to play and pleads with
the officials to change his punishment
meanwhile with the majority of the
players being able to play around the
memory tactics Chihaya and the others
pull ahead to win that match also
episode 11 who next matches again show
yo hi We're kimonos benched again
because he had been taking notes on the
other teams all day so he's exhausted
these
nose pay off though as the others were
struggling but then remember some of the
advice he gave them about how show
you'll play allowing them to get an edge
and win back over two out of two whose
punishment has changed thanks to Shinobu
he instead has to write an essay
apologizing for his actions and he isn't
allowed to go cheer for Chihaya and
Taichi
well the others have to prepare for the
semi finals against Takashi first girls
Academy which is the team that Western
rep mega move Osaka is on the girls team
play in the same order and only change
if they are against a strong opponent
yeah feeling threatened by me Sousa WA
they keep their order where she higher
goes against their ace Osaka II episode
well as the semies are about to get
underway Hoku is also going against the
defending champions Fujisaki high the
match starts and she is right away that
Osaka had improved since her loss to
Yumi and we get some flashbacks of her
working hard after the defeat Jiraiya
falls behind initially and away notices
so she passes along some positive vibes
which inspires she hyah defy back
episode 13 despite Chihaya trying to
rally it's not that simple as you Sokka
keeps abnormally calm and collected
increasing her lead gia comes to the
conclusion where Osaka is like her but
without a good teacher whereas she has
had a death booth teams fight for
momentum but neither give ground and
with chihaya's starting to fight back
Osaka starts to get a little bit more
intense episode 14 everybody was so
caught up in me Sousa was matched that
they didn't notice Haku okay to be
getting slaughtered by Fujisaki which
ends in a four to one victory
surprise surprise Mishneh is the first
one to fall in his match breaking the
score two one zero
Osaka starts to gain more momentum and
seems to be getting faster even taking
the Chihaya fudou card gia does her best
to keep it close but she ends up losing
to Osaka Oh a anti she managed to win
their matches making the score 2-2 now
all eyes are on kimono in a sudden-death
round he goes on to win the last card
securing their spot in the finals
against Fujisaki episode 15 before the
finals it's revealed that in the semi
Zoe had jammed her finger and it's
gotten really swollen to prevent it from
getting worse she sits the finals out
and Tsukuba has to take her spot
Fujisaki makes some last-minute changes
to their lineup subbing integral
Lyonne Yamashiro who gets placed up
against Chihaya shinobi was curious as
to why auditor wants to go watch the
team so badly so she decides to stop in
and watch the episode 16 is like season
1 and a recap episode II episode 17 as
the finals get underway we learned that
Eon has an advantage because her
grandmother is one of the certified
readers for some players like Zuo the
reader makes a massive difference
saudi-owned is able to play really well
with certain readers G aya goes for a
card that is defended by the own and
even though it doesn't seem to be
injured she is still feeling pain in her
index finger
Shinobu who had initially forgotten
about ji-hye and their match last year
remembers her after seeing her speed
with some of the cards the other four
pick up on the fact that she is hurting
which makes them all the more determined
to step up their game for the win
episode 18 everybody is losing with
Chihaya down six cards niche two down
three tight she down four and both
Tsukuba and kimono down seven even
though they're behind they try fighting
back but coming I was the first one to
lose his match we'd get a short
flashback of how Shinobu was forced to
play alone so she could get better which
is why she thinks team competitions are
pointless
Tsukuba is the next one who's bringing
it to match point while chihaya's finger
seems to be getting worse episode 19
after being behind the whole game Taichi
is able to even things out after his
opponent makes a double fall despite her
injury Chihaya goes on to win her match
making the score 2-1 it's now up to
Taichi and Nisha who both end up in
another sudden-death having learned from
their mistake in the last sudden death
against Hoku Academy they are the ones
to synchronize their cards this time
thanks to their planning the card red is
on their side allowing them to easily
secure the match making them the
national high school champions episode
20 editin meets up with them after the
match and later Chihaya has to go to get
her finger looked at while edita is left
alone with Taichi
he tells Taichi that he is planning on
going to college in Tokyo so he's gonna
be moving back soon over to Chihaya
where they aren't sure what's wrong with
her fingers so they refer her to a
bigger Hospital while suggesting that
she not play in the individual
tournament she still wants to compete so
she decides that she's gonna use her
left hand to play in the first round she
is against you make a coup Benicia in
the team
against Akashi first girls school when
the match starts Chihaya obviously falls
behind from not being used to playing
with her left hand episode 21 audited
Shinobu both finished perfect games
without losing a single card so he goes
to watch Chihaya she has fallen pretty
far behind but realize that her cards
are set up for her right hand she gets
the idea to flip the positioning and
after doing this starts to make her
comeback she is able to pull the game
back into reach and wins with the two
card advantage Rishta also made it
through to the next round but that joy
is short-lived when he gets placed
against a data in the second round keep
in mind that he lost city girl who
couldn't beat Chihaya using her left
hand so I don't think he's breaking out
it says oh people out armor anytime soon
the world is shocked as auditor wins but
this makes niche to all the more
determined to get better
gie gets placed against Kaku Natsume we
don't watch the match but she manages to
win again for the third round she hyah
gets her rematch against Shinobu so she
decides she's gonna play with her right
hand despite her injury he episode 22
ji-hye I can't keep up with her injury
but she does manage to take she Nobu's
best card as a consolation prize in the
end she lost by 23 cards being
eliminated from the tournament
afterwards she no we was thinking back
on her isolation when she I approaches
her saying that they will play again in
the queen match / - she Bobby who
managed to win a couple of matches but
was eliminated in the third round
meanwhile Taichi had made it all the way
to the Class B semi-finals squaring off
against hito Yepez Oh 23 in the
semi-finals of Class A she know who's
taking on Osaka while a data is against
the Fujisaki high school captain Ryoga
Amato Shinobu goes on to win by 14 cards
while auditive wins his match by 12
cards advancing them both into the
finals where they will finally face off
against each other Oh way finds Chihaya
and tells her that she lost in the Class
C semies bakoma now made it to the
finals she also tells her about Taichi
beating hero so he is in the Class B
finals with his promotion to Class A on
the line even though she wants to watch
the Class A match she decides that it's
more important to support Taichi he
faces up against Lyon in the finals but
his playing sloppy because he wants to
finish fast so that she hyah can go
watch the Class A match
don't can't match his stamina and the
reader was different so she didn't have
her normal edge this costs her the match
and Taichi wins by nine cards securing
his promotion to Class A he episode 24
turns out Tsukuba had made it to the
Class D finals and ends up winning but
nobody noticed until he was on match
point
well we hop over to the Class A finals
where a d'état has a lead over Shinobu
nobody in the crowd can even tell who's
winning the cards because of how close
and fast they both are despite the high
pressure Auto Tech keeps his cool
demeanor and eventually pulls out the
victory giving the Queen her first loss
in years after the match he makes a
comment about her having a fever so she
may not have been playing at full
capacity but it was still close match
episode 25 with komen out winning the
Class C finals also they have all of the
champions gather for the award ceremony
following the tournament chihaya's
referred to multiple hospitals who are
all confused by her finger after some
tests they finally come to the
conclusion that it's encontró mitosis
which is part of the bone in her finger
softening because she can't just ignore
it she plans to have an operation where
he puts him for a material inside the
bone after her surgery away picks up on
the fact that she hiya might be falling
for audit --is so she tells Taichi to
try harder Joep back a bit so before
they left the tournament the Fujisaki
coach Midori Socko Tazawa had recorded
the Class A match and gave Chihaya a
copy
Chihaya calls her to thank her again and
while on the phone socket is out what
invites her and the others to a Fujisaki
to take a data can of course she agrees
to this but Oh a wingman's Taichi by
making sure him and she I are the only
ones to go which is where the season
ends I'm gonna be doing the future
seasons and that'll be in the bottom
left whenever I'm finished with it where
you can check out all the Chi high of
food who recaps in this playlist here
you can also find the links in the
description below and the only thing I
hate more than intros is outro